(audience applauds)
Please welcome someone I am one of the biggest fans of.
Justin Sutherland!
(audience applauds)
Oh, Drew.
Thank you so much for having me.
It's amazing.
Now what are we making?
Because macaroni and cheese is my favorite food
on planet Earth.
But I've never seen this.
I know, well, I do know that macaroni and cheese
is your favorite food.
So that's why we're making it.
It's pasta week.
(audience applauds)
It is!
I know that, come on.
Yes.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Sorry, I'm back.
No, it's okay.
I never left, but I'm very excited.
Yes.
Will you teach us how to do this?
Oh my gosh, that would be like,
my biggest pleasure in the world, let's do it.
Thank you!
Awesome.
I feel the same way.
(Justin laughs)
Now we're starting with a roux.
Yes, so you should have some butter melting
right there in that pot.
Yep. All right.
So here's our butter.
Here's our butter.
Here's our flour.
You're just gonna throw all that in.
And mixy, mixy, mixy.
And what you wanna do, I mean,
technically it should be equal parts
to flour and butter,
and you're gonna get kind of that peanut buttery color
right there.
So we're gonna take some milk.
Milk?
Yeah, and we're gonna add that in
and just incorporate it with our roux here.
(audience laughs)
And that flour and butter is what's gonna help
Aaah.
thicken that up.
All right, so we have our little spice blend here.
We've got some onion powder, some garlic powder,
some smoked paprika, cayenne, a little black pepper.
Dump it all in.
So then after that, so normally,
we'd let that reduce down a little bit.
It's gonna get a little thicker.
But we're gonna slide right over here.
You mean like this?
Like this.
And that is the thickness that we want
our roux with our spices to be, yeah?
So here's where our mac and cheese
gets a little bit different.
So normally, we would just do heavy cream.
But we have a mixture of sour cream
and cottage cheese here.
And what that's gonna do,
it just adds a little acidity.
Kind of that just extra oomph
that you're not gonna get from a normal cheese sauce.
So that's what makes ours a little different.
So just go ahead and dump that right in
to your little bathtub.
Oh!
(audience laughs)
This is really beautiful.
I love a sour cream cream cheese approach.
I'm all in.
(audience laughs)
So here we have, we've pre-melted
a little American style cheese,
and that's just gonna give even more creaminess,
more cheesiness.
Make your bath tub even more delicious.
Are you melty over there?
I'm melting everywhere.
(Justin laughs)
Let's add some pasta.
There we go.
And there's not enough calories in here yet,
so we're just gonna finish it off
by mounting it with some butter,
because butter makes everything better.
And the butter is gonna give
a little thickening action?
Yeah, and it's like that mouth feel.
It's velvety, it coats it.
I mean, butter does so many things.
So I think our pasta's perfect right now.
We're gonna take our spoon.
I think you have a bowl over there.
However much you want,
we're just gonna spoon right into this bowl.
So here's where our mac and cheese
gets a little bit different.
We take these hot crispy cheesy...
Flaming!
(audience applauds)
Flaming puffs.
And we are gonna put those all over the top.
As much as you would like.
I'm gonna center it.
Look at that plating.
Wow.
From you,
the amazing chef, are you kidding me?
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I cannot believe, Justin, you would say that.
Thank you.
Oh, and then a little-
It depends, if you like them pre-crushed,
if you want them whole.
If you want a little bit of both.
You do your thing, girl.
Shall we have some?
Bon appetite.
Cheers, thank you so much
for making mac and cheese with me, Drew.
Thank you so much for teaching me
how to make your beautiful mac and cheese.
I mean...
(audience applauds)
This is so layered, so pleasurable.
So not what you think it's gonna taste like.
Right.
I will say, it really puts a new spin on mac and cheese.
I kind of thought I was gonna have familiar territory.
Not at all.
It's that sour cream, it's the crunchy bits on top.
It's the little cheese pillows.
You completely transformed the dish.
It's incredible.
I'm just gonna take one more bite to make sure.
As you should, as you should.
No, it's incredible.
Thank you so much, Justin Sutherland.
(audience applauds)
New episode of "Fast Foodies"
airs on Thursdays at 10 PM on truTV.
One of my favorite shows.
And also, catch "Taste the Culture"
with Justin Sutherland on YouTube,
which is where you go and explore women.
Yes.
Throughout the country.
And their culinary backgrounds.
Women, just BIPOC, just you know,
people of color and females
and telling untold stories in the food world
that you know, would normally not get a platform.
So you know, I wanna take the spotlight off me
and go find new stories that need to be told.
All right, well we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)